Controversial New York congressman,
Republican George
Santos, now
officially under investigation
by the House Ethics Committee.
It will look into multiple issues
from his campaign finances
to a sexual misconduct allegations.
Our great reporters are back
and Santos is now infamous
for just lying and lying
and lying and lying.
But the substance of these allegations
are quite serious.
The committee has acknowledged
its investigation
potential unlawful activity
by his 2022 campaign,
potential violations
of federal conflict of interest
laws for work
he did
for a firm providing fiduciary services.
He may have failed
to disclose information
on his statements filed with the House
and the sexual misconduct allegation
that he made
an inappropriate advance toward
someone seeking a job in his office.
So America knows Jorge Santos is a liar.
That's a serious list.
Yeah, it is a serious lesson.
George Henderson says
House career is hanging by a thread.
And it is this,
you know,
typically the House Ethics Committee,
Senate Ethics Committee,
they do these investigations.
It's a slap on the wrist.
They get admonished.
No one cares.
This is different
because not only is the scope
very, very serious,
but the Republican leadership.
Kevin McCarthy has now staked
Santos his career on the outcome of this.
At the promise of that time and again,
as I've pressed him on this,
others have pressed him on this.
He's now pointing that,
as he says, if they find any wrongdoing,
that's when they could push him out.
And how do you push him out?
An expulsion resolution in the House
requires two thirds majority.
Kevin McCarthy
gets behind the expulsion
resolution of Jorge Santos.
He is done
he's not going to be a House
member anymore.
That's what is.
But the question is,
if you go through that serious list,
how House Ethics Committees
and I'll get to another one in a minute.
These investigations
tend to go on forever.
And ever and ever and ever.
So does Kevin McCarthy.
You know,
does he want to get his wish,
but not right away
because he needs Jorge Santos, his vote?
Well,
he does continue to need Jorge Santos.
His vote it's a math problem.
I recently did a story
about shamelessness
in American politics in this new age.
Long story. And it was a long story.
And I working
and I interviewed
former Congressman Anthony Weiner,
who left in a cloud of shame.
One thing he told me that I think
is relevant
to the Santos situation is
it wasn't just the reporters hounding him
It wasn't just his colleagues
telling him
they didn't want to be seen with him.
It was also that he was facing
hundreds of thousands of dollars
in legal fees to actually properly
defend himself
against a house ethics investigation.
So is this another weight on the scale
for Santos?
Who knows?
But I do know that in that case,
there was
the ethics
investigation wasn't
just that it would take forever, and
but that it would be expensive to defend.
And especially the New York
the other New York freshman
who came in with him
that's why Kevin McCarthy is speaker.
They flipped all these seats in New York,
Michael, all.
As I've said before, Jorge Santos conduct
his conduct
is embarrassing and unbecoming.
If he had any dignity, he would resign
Your point is a potential question down
the road. This has become too expensive.
But at the moment,
he seems to think staying
is how you raise that money
for the legal fees.
That's right. That's right.
And even just as well, while he stays,
even if this report is delayed
and the Ethics
Committee investigation
does go on for a while,
we were talking about
does that benefit the Republican Party?
Does the spotlight move off?
Can you maintain his vote?
You're seeing just right there
his fellow colleagues in New York
continue to criticize him,
even maybe
leadership in the House
is trying to balance this out
and about his peers in the House,
including Republicans
who at times of criticism or crisis
have not always been forthcoming
with criticism towards their colleagues,
are also starting to heat up
the rhetoric as well.
It doesn't seem like
the scrutiny
is going to tend to leave at this.
To help me understand the case,
the continuing investigation
of Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez,
you know, she went to the Met Gala.
She wore that dress.
She had hair and makeup
it was all provided for her.
She says she made the reimbursements
for it after the fact.
But the Ethics Committee says
if not for the
opening the
review, it
appears she may not have paid
for several thousand dollars
worth of goods
and service provided to her.
So they're trying to get a timeline of
did you only make the reimbursement
when we started questioning you?
Is that the issue?
Yeah, that is
and is requirements
and strict rules
about how you accept gifts,
how you disclose gifts,
what you can accept.
Threshold for that.
The question is, did
she violate any of those rules?
The committee announced that it's
extending its investigation,
meaning it is still ongoing.
So it's not going to rise
to the level of Jorge
Santo's offense
where they may push him out of the house
of the outcome
of the ethics investigation.
But she could face them,
you know,
and admonishment,
as I was mentioning earlier
from the House Ethics Committee,
if she's not acted properly by her
team, says they're confident
they can answer the questions
then it will go away.
But we'll say we'll stay on top
of that one as it plays out.